yeah i was feeling my own attention get
worse and worse it felt like with each
year that passed doing things that
require deep focus like reading a book
were more and more like running up a
down escalator i really didn't want to
think about it i put it off and it was
really
looking at the young people
in my life
and seeing that a lot of them were
really whirring at the speed of snapchat
were really unable to focus that made me
realize i'm going to have to look into
this so i ended up going on a big
journey all over the world they
interviewed over 200 of the leading
experts on what boosts attention and
what causes it to get worse they showed
me
many of the factors that degrade
attention have been getting much worse
in recent years and we're actually in a
really big crisis and your attention
didn't collapse your attention has been
stolen by these 12 big powerful forces
and it's it's something called the
switch cost effect which i didn't really
understand about before i i read but
part of your book just explain what that
is
so if you're interrupted it takes you 23
minutes to get back to the same level of
focus that you had before you were
interrupted but most people
never get 23 minutes spare so we're
constantly operating if you think you're
doing more than one thing at once which
lots of us do i might think don't worry
i won't but i could check my text while
i'm talking to you it turns out when you
do that you're focusing and refocusing
your brain
and that really significantly degrades
your ability to think it doesn't feel
like it we feel like we're operating at
full function but it really uh screws
with your ability to think and pay
attention and we're all being
interrupted all the time so we've got to
deal with this at two levels all the 12
factors that are degrading our attention
have got kind of two levels of solution
one is we've got to protect ourselves
and our kids at an individual level i
learned about loads of practical ways we
can do that
but also we've got to take on the forces
that are doing this to us at the moment
it's a bit like someone is constantly
pouring itching powder into our heads
and then they're leaning forward and
saying you know um you might want to
learn how to meditate then you wouldn't
scratch so much right of course
meditation has real value i'm in favor
of it but we've also got to stop the
people who are pouring the itching
powder on us all the time and one of
them is exactly what you're saying
constant interruptions that degrade our
ability to ever get into a state of deep
focus
and this these constant interruptions
they actually cause cognitive
degradation we are actually
rotting our brains you've concluded
well it was really chilling i went to
interview one of the leading
neuroscientists in the world a man named
professor earl miller who's at mit the
massachusetts institute of technology
and that was the phrase he used to me
that we are living in what he called a
perfect storm of cognitive degradation
there were so many scientists it was
because i didn't realize how big this
was um i could feel it in myself i could
see it in the kids that i love i didn't
realize how
how
deep this crisis goes until i went to
interview so many scientists who said
similar things like that the leading
expert on children's attention problems
in the united states professor joel nigg
said to me
that we are living in what he called an
attentional pathogenic environment it's
one where it's getting harder for almost
everyone to to focus and pay attention
but the really important thing to know
is there are solutions when we
understand the
real range of things that happening to
us and the factors degrading our
attention range really widely from the
food we eat to the hours we don't sleep
once we understand these causes we can
begin to deal with them at these two
levels and it requires us to change the
way we think about this we're not
medieval peasants begging king
zuckerberg the owner of facebook for
little crumbs of attention from his
table we're the free citizens of
democracies and we own our own minds and
we're going to have to fight for our
minds and fight for our children's minds
to resist this really severe degradation
of our attention that so many of your
viewers will be feeling
so so briefly it's about switching off
and i live somewhere with no mobile
signal which i just love because when i
go home i know that that that box on
that i put on the bench isn't going to
ping or ring um it's about switching off
and it's about finding something that
that you can focus on that you enjoy
and really refocusing your attention on
different things in a different way
that's one aspect of it actually i was
surprised because i thought tech was the
main cause actually in the research that
i did i learned that actually tech is
only one of the twelve it's not the
biggest there are actually many factors
that are playing out for the people
watching now that are degrading their
attention that are worse than the issues
with tech and actually making them more
vulnerable to the tech give you a very
simple example we sleep an hour less
than we did in 1942 children sleep 85
minutes less when you're sleeping your
brain is repairing when you sleep less
you are much less able to pay attention
throughout the day that's just one of
many factors we've got to deal with and
i think this is so important because
if you can't pay attention you can't
achieve any of your goals everyone
watching think about anything you've
ever achieved in your life whether it's
starting a business being a good parent
it required a huge amount of sustained
attention that attention is breaking
down the average american college
student now focuses on any one task but
only 65 seconds the average office
worker only focuses on any one task on
average for three minutes we can't
achieve our goals if we're living in
this way we don't have to live this way
i've been to places that built solutions
from moscow to miami that are places
that have overcome these detention
problems